[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour un nouveau numéro de
Parlement Hebdo l'émission qui revient
sur l'actualité de la semaine au
Parlement et pour commenter cette
semaine aux accueillons cette semaine
Benjamin saint tuiles bonjour vous êtes
député du Nord et porte-parole du groupe
parlementaire l'iode liberté indépendant
outre-mer et territoire et on va parler
cette semaine de la proposition loi de
votre groupe pour abroger le recul de
l'âge de départ à la retraite à 64 ans
le débat est prévu dans l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée nationale le 8 juin mais la
majorité présidentielle et le
gouvernement estiment que le texte n'est
pas recevable sur le plan financier et
que donc le débat ne doit pas avoir lieu
on parlera également d'immigration
puisque le gouvernement tente de trouver
une majorité sur son projet loi alors
que les républicains ont dévoilé cette
semaine deux propositions de loi sur ce
sujet et notamment un texte qui prévoit
de modifier la Constitution pour durcir
notre politique migratoire et puis les
députés se penchent en ce moment sur le
projet loi de programmation militaire un
budget de 413 milliards d'euros pour les
armées sur 7 ans avec un objectif
permettra à la France de faire face aux
nouvelle menaces on parle d'abord des
retraites puisque votre groupe Benjamin
Saint-Huile présente donc ce texte pour
aborder la mesure phare de la réforme le
recul à 64 ans de l'âge de départ la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales à saisie Éric Coquerel
président de la commission des finances
sur la recevabilité du texte écoutez
effectivement je l'ai saisi ayant été
moi-même interpellé par de très nombreux
députés de la majorité présidentielle
qui effectivement se posait à juste
titre la question de la recevabilité je
l'ai saisi officiellement par écrit je
comprends que il ne s'agit pas d'une
paille c'est il s'agit quand même de
plus de 20 milliards donc la question se
pose le débat on l'a eu déjà il y a plus
de 175 heures de débat en séance en
commission la loi a été donc adoptée
voter au Sénat et donc on remet une
pièce dans le juke-box
inutilement je vais effectivement
chercher les arguments juridiques
en lien avec les jurisprudences
qu'est-ce qui a été fait par le passé
par rapport des propositions de loi en
lien aussi avec les compensations parce
qu'il y en a prévu dans dans la loi pour
voir si je peux la déclarer recevable en
tout cas je vais le chercher je peux
vous donner la réponse aujourd'hui mais
je vais aller essayer d'aller dans ce
sens là comme je le fais d'ailleurs en
général sur toutes les propositions de
loi parce que j'estime qu'il faut
laisser l'initiative parlementaire
prendre le pas et avoir j'allais dire le
bénéfice du doute par rapport à
l'article 40
est-ce que vous craignez que votre
proposition de loi qui abroche donc le
recul de l'âge de départ à la retraite à
64 ans soit déclaré irrecevable sur le
plan financier je crois que les choses
sont claires c'est la panique du côté du
gouvernement et de la majorité
parlementaire caché ce vote que je ne
saurais voir ici il y a une forme de jeu
de dupe depuis la Cinquième République
des propositions de loi sont déposées
évidemment elle coûte de l'argent mais
par principe et pour permettre que le
travail parlementaire puisse se faire
dans un climat de sérénité il est
toujours accepté en l'occurrence cette
proposition de loi elle a été reçue par
le Bureau de l'Assemblée nationale et
donc valider en tant que tel la seule
personne qui puisse être aujourd'hui
interpellé c'est le président de la
commission des finances Éric Coquerel
qui aura à regarder et à se positionner
sur ce texte je suis inquiet quand
j'entends mais la première ministre et
ensuite les ministres et secrétaire
d'État se succédaient pour dire oh mon
dieu il y a un caractère irrecevable
presque IR responsable alors même que
dans leur majorité il y a encore
quelques semaines nous étudions des
textes qui devaient coûter plusieurs
milliards d'euros et que ça ne posait
problème à personne et puis je veux dire
un mot quand même parce que il faut que
les masques tombent on parle de 20
milliards il y a quelques semaines
c'était 15 milliards bon les choses
avancent vite en réalité il y a deux
articles dans la proposition de loi le
premier celui dont il ne veulent pas
entendre parler c'est l'abrogation du
recul de l'âge légal le deuxième c'est
une conférence sociale convoquée dans le
deuxième semestre 2023 pour trouver des
solutions pour retrouver l'équilibre et
donc quand on vous dit c'est
irresponsable il y aura 15 milliards 20
milliards c'est pas possible pour la
France en fait c'est un mensonge dans
l'impact l'étude d'impact qui a été
porté par le gouvernement les mesures
sur le deuxième semestre elles ont un
impact de 270 millions sur des budgets
qui concernent les retraites à plus de
300 milliards soyons sérieux disons la
vérité aux Français les Français dehors
ils veulent que les représentants du
peuple vote et le gouvernement a peur
oui selon vous Emmanuel Macron a peur
d'aller au vote sur ce texte à
l'Assemblée nationale oui c'est nouveau
le président de la République ou plus
exactement aujourd'hui le gouvernement
est la majorité relative au Parlement on
peur du vote des députés bien sûr qu'ils
ont peur de perdre parce qu'ils savent
le caractère symbolique ils savent
qu'ils sont passés en force alors que la
rue s'est mobilisée pendant des mois
jusqu'à se mettre en difficulté
financière
à travers des grèves pacifiques que nous
avons travaillé dans l'Assemblée
nationale pour dire notre désaccord et
qu'en face nous avons eu des gens qui
nous ont dit la main sur le cœur mais
rassurez-vous sur ce texte central
évidemment qu'il y aura un vote et puis
comptant les uns après les autres les
défections notamment chez les
républicains ils ont décidé de
déclencher 49-3 et depuis c'est la
fracturation du pays depuis c'est
l'incompréhension depuis c'est les
casseroles et depuis il y a une forme de
blocage donc aujourd'hui sortir du
blocage sortir de la situation dans
laquelle le gouvernement nous a sortir
de cette ornière c'est recevoir la main
tendue du groupe iode qui dit votons et
s'il refuse de recevoir si votre
proposition de loi est déclarée et
recevable vous irez tout de même
jusqu'au bout vous poursuivrez le combat
jusqu'à aller par exemple jusqu'à motion
de censure nous nous avons dit depuis le
départ que nous voulions faire confiance
au vote et que si votre il y a nous
respecterons le résultat de ce vote de
deux choses l'une ou finalement
l'abrogation est prononcée par un vote
majoritaire ce que nous croyons et nous
en appelons à la sagesse et à la
responsabilité du chef de l'État où ce
vote est finalement rejeté et
l'abrogation est rejetée et nous en
prendrons acte respecter la démocratie
c'est accepter le fait majoritaire d'un
côté comme de l'autre je note qu'il y a
une appréciation à géométrie très très
variable de la majorité parlementaire
justement on va parler de cette majorité
potentielle autour de votre texte sur
cet abrogation de la réforme des
retraites mais juste si ce texte est
n'est pas examiné déclaré et rece est-ce
que le groupe yote déposera une motion
de censure ensuite c'est trop tôt pour
le dire moi je fais confiance à la
sagesse des uns et des autres nous
voulons sortir de l'ornière tout est
bloqué aujourd'hui dehors il y a des
urgences sociales il y a une inflations
qui continuent à galoper vous voyez bien
les violences auxquelles nous sommes
confrontés le service public en général
l'hôpital en particulier étant grande
difficulté nous voulons apporter des
réponses concrètes et immédiates mais
aujourd'hui il y a une crise passion et
un blocage qui est lié à la manière de
faire du gouvernement à cette surdité
coupable du gouvernement donc il faut
bien en sortir et comme ils le font
aucune proposition d'apaisement en
responsabilité nous voulons apaiser je
n'imagine pas qu'ils vont choisir une
fois encore d'éviter le vote parce que
ce serait incompris ça et si sur le feu
pour vous ah je crois que il y a une
forme d'irresponsabilité à envisager
bloquer cette proposition parce que il
la vive vraisemblablement comme un piège
politique alors que c'est une main
tendue qui leur permettrait d'apaiser le
pays depuis quand on a peur du vote à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est nouveau
quand même et est-ce que vous pensez que
vous aurez une majorité sur cette
proposition de loi est-ce que vous
discutez notamment avec certains députés
les républicains qui pourraient vous
apporter leur voix oui on discute avec
les autres groupes politiques mais plus
que ce que nous pensons c'est la
réaction du gouvernement et de la
minorité présidentielle qui témoigne du
fait qu'il y a un vrai sujet sur la
capacité que nous pourrions avoir à être
majoritaire sur ce texte voyez bien
comme c'est la panique voyez bien comme
ça 30 comme ça change d'avis ils
trouveront toutes les ficelles possibles
et imaginables de l'article 40 que nous
découvrons a peut-être utilisé la voix
des amendements a peut-être utilisé
l'article 44-3 sur le vote bloqué pour
essayer de biaiser les choses bref
dehors les gens ne comprennent pas cette
attitude ils veulent savoir si oui ou
non à l'Assemblée il y a une majorité
pour abroger ce texte nous nous savons
que oui il y a une majorité pour abroger
et donc pour vous les Français
s'intéressent à votre initiative vous ne
pensez qui sont déjà passés à autre
chose non la réforme des retraites ça
continue à être dans leur préoccupations
ils n'ont pas tourné la page je pense
qu'ils sont très attentifs à ce qui se
passe les dernières enquêtes d'opinion
témoignent qu'il valide à plus de deux
tiers des interrogés la proposition de
loi et la volonté qu'il y ait un vote
que il y ait une forme de lassitude je
peux tout à fait l'entendre et le
partager mais là latitude elle est liée
à quoi au sentiment que nous ne sommes
pas entendu les gens ils ont défilé
pendant des semaines pacifiquement ils
ont pris le temps de faire grève dans ta
d'entamer leur pouvoir d'achat je croise
des gens tous les jours qui me disent
bravo merci de continuer nous ne pouvons
plus descendre dans la rue non pas que
nous ne vous accompagnons pas dans votre
perspective mais parce que
financièrement ça n'est plus possible
rapidement pour conclure sur cette
proposition à la proposition de loi
eliotes si jamais l'Assemblée nationale
adoptait ce texte il serait normalement
rejeté par le snap puisque la majorité
de droite du Sénat et pour la réforme
des retraites est-ce que vous admettez
qu'au fond ce texte n'ira jamais au bout
nous nous avons considéré depuis le
premier jour que essayer de renvoyer
dans les cordes cette proposition de loi
en disant oui mais ça n'ira pas au Sénat
ça n'était pas un argument sérieux ce
que veulent savoir les gens c'est ce que
pensent leur députés ils veulent savoir
s'ils les représentent les seuls qui les
représentent sont d'accord ou pas avec
cette réforme et moi je pense que si il
y a un vote sur ce texte il y aura un
vote majoritaire pour labrogation et que
c'est de la responsabilité du Président
de la République d'en prendre acte en
changeant de gouvernement d'abord en
prenant acte que cette réforme n'est pas
acceptée en changeant de méthode et en
faisant en sorte en quelques mois on
réécrive une méthode concertée partagée
où on peut réformer le pays sur les
retraites sans crisper tout le monde et
sans être dans une situation de blocage
et d'irrespect pour faire une autre
réforme des retraites évidemment mais ça
peut se faire en quelques mois je crois
en concertation avec les organismes
syndicales et patronales que nous avons
vu ces dernières semaines et qui
confirment leur volonté de faire on va
parler d'immigration maintenant puisque
pendant que le ministre de l'Intérieur
pas mal de Darmanin consultent les
parlementaires sur son projet loi les
républicains ont décidé de dévoiler deux
propositions de loi sur son TEC sur ce
thème notamment une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle pour et bien durcir la
politique migratoire des textes qui ont
besoin qui auront besoin pardon des
voies des centristes pour être adopté au
Sénat et ça ce n'est pas gagné Flora
sauvage les républicains durcissent le
ton sur l'immigration alors que
l'exécutif a besoin de la droite pour
faire voter sa future loi prévue à
l'automne LR prend les devants avec deux
propositions de loi sur ce thème cher à
la droite nous proposons donc un projet
de rupture à la fois audacieux et
sérieux pour mettre un coup d'arrêt à
l'immigration de masse les Français
doivent pouvoir choisir qui ils
accueillent qu'ils ne souhaitent pas
accueillir et qui n'a plus sa place sur
notre territoire premier texte une
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
afin de permettre la convocation d'un
référendum sur l'immigration ce que la
loi actuelle ne permet pas l'objectif
est aussi de faire valoir la primauté du
droit national sur le droit européen il
y a pas un autre phénomène qui est au
temps bouleversé la société française
depuis un demi-siècle sans que les
Français n'étaient jamais consultés moi
je souhaite que un référendum puisse
avoir lieu sur le sujet de l'immigration
pour ça faut réviser la Constitution
interpeller au Sénat le ministre de
l'Intérieur dénonce un frexit migratoire
et rappelle les lignes rouges du
gouvernement vous proposez pour certains
dispositions de sortir de la Convention
de Genève de 1951 de sortir des traités
de l'Union européenne et si c'est tout à
fait vrai c'est une question importante
que ce frexit migratoire il faut
évidemment que nous puissions échanger
sur les propositions constitutionnelles
mais avouez que c'est ici nous faisons
un projet de lordinaire je veux redire
que à la demande de la première ministre
j'ai entrepris des négociations les
discussions avec le groupe LR du Sénat
avec les centrist avec tous les autres
groupes qui le souhaitent bien
évidemment pour je l'espère à l'automne
discuter de ce texte s'il exécutif est
embarrassé le président du groupe
centriste au Sénat prend ses dist
vis-à-vis de son allié LR nous nous
allons faire nos propositions également
ils seront différentes à l'évidence nous
sommes européens et nous sommes très
attentifs au cadre européen la
Constitution peut la modifier mais ça
prend du temps il faut les trois
cinquième je vous rappelle affaibli dans
les yeux urnes la droite parvient à
imposer son tempo et réclame la
suppression de l'aide médicale d'État
pour les sans-papiers jusqu'ici opposés
à sa disparition la majorité
présidentielle semble désormais prête à
négocier
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec les
républicains est-ce qu'il faut déroger à
certains traités internationaux
européens pour reprendre le contrôle de
la politique migratoire je parle aux
républicains où je parle à ceux qui
copient les textes proposés par Madame
Le Pen faut dire les choses avec clarté
qu'il y ait une volonté dans ce pays de
réguler c'est tout à fait nécessaire que
il y ait la volonté d'encadrer les
choses différemment pourquoi pas faire
croire aux gens on va réviser la
Constitution alors que ça nécessite des
procédures complexes qui n'ont aucune
majorité en la matière et ne pas assumer
que perdu dans leur idéologie il
hésitent entre une partie qui regarde
Emmanuel Macron en cherchant les
différences et l'autre qui regarde
Madame Le Pen avec des yeux de Chimène
moi je suis inquiet la droite
républicaine celle que j'ai connue celle
qui m'a fait grandir autour de Jacques
Chirac même si nous avions des
différences elle me semble un peu perdue
dans cette aventure et je trouve que
les républicains ils cherchent
aujourd'hui à reprendre un peu de
lumière parce qu'objectivement ils sont
dans une situation de cul-de-sac sans
issue et je pense que ceux qui
choisissent de copier Madame Le Pen
prennent un grand risque alors les LR
demande un référendum sur l'immigration
est-ce que c'est souhaitable pour vous
c'est ni souhaitable ni envisageable à
ce stade il faut d'abord réviser la
Constitution et ça dépend ce que vous
voulez poser comme question aux gens et
ça dépend dans quel contexte vous posez
les sujets évidemment que si vous agitez
les peurs en permanence en disant
regardez tous ces gens cette vague
submersive pour reprendre des
expressions qu'ils utilisent à tout
rompre vous agitez une inquiétude dans
la population qui va amener à un vote de
de
défense en quelque sorte moi je pense
que sur ces sujets il faut être très
précis nous avons besoin de mieux
réguler mais nous avons besoin
d'immigration ça embête de dire ça
aujourd'hui mais dans nos hôpitaux nous
avons besoin de main d'oeuvre dans un
certain nombre de secteurs extrêmement
tendus je pense tendance à la
restauration nous sommes très heureux
d'avoir de la main d'oeuvre étrangère et
les propositions qui ont été faites en
ce sens pour la régularisation de ceux
qui sont sur le territoire national
depuis longtemps qui assume des
responsabilités qui travaillent par le
travail cela je crois doivent être
accompagnés donc je pense qu'il faut
arrêter de copier Madame Le Pen il faut
relever ses mensonges il y en a beaucoup
mais pour ça il faut être sérieux et je
considère que les républicains à la
matière choisissent la facilité ce qui
ne les honore pas en tout cas dans le
même temps Gérald de Darmanin le
ministre de l'Intérieur travail sur son
projet de loi immigration consulte les
parlementaires à cette Intex qui en même
temps facilite les expulsions tout en
proposant de régulariser les
travailleurs sans papiers dans les
secteurs économiques en tension est-ce
que le groupe lyode pourrait voter ce
texte et si oui il y a quelles
conditions le groupe lot il fera ce
qu'il a toujours fait il sera en
situation de proposer un certain nombre
d'amendements d'améliorations nous nous
considérons que permettre à ceux qui
sont déjà ici et qui travaillent de
pouvoir être en situation régulière
c'est souhaitable nous considérons qu'il
faut pouvoir mieux régul après il y a
des choses sur lesquelles il faut être
plus attentif je suis attentif à titre
personnel par exemple à la question du
travailleur jetable qui serait reçu avec
intérêt au moment de la tension et qu'on
remercierait après une fois que la
tension serait derrière nous je pense
qu'il faut faire attention à cela quand
on accepte que les gens viennent ici
contribuer à la production de la
richesse et donc au partage de la valeur
espérée derrière on doit les respecter
il faut travailler à cela et je crois
que il faut le faire avec modération
sérieux et dans un dialogue constructif
alors le gouvernement a beaucoup
tergiversé sur ce sujet de l'immigration
et eu un premier texte à l'ordre du jour
qui a commencé à être examiné par les
sénateurs puis retirer puis voici ce
nouveau texte qui devrait être en séance
bientôt en tout cas dévoiler en juillet
est-ce que vous pensez que Gérard
Darmanin va trouver une majorité sur
l'immigration sur son projet de loi
immigration pour être honnête je ne suis
pas sûr que ce gouvernement sera en
situation dans les mois qui viennent de
continuer à travailler comme il le fait
je ne vise pas spécifiquement Gérald
Darmanin on a voté
la locmi il y a quelques semaines et
nous l'avons fait avec force et il est
capable de construire des des
passerelles je l'imagine mais je trouve
que de manière générale la méthode qui
est choisie par le gouvernement c'est
une méthode qui vise à considérer que
les œillères d'hier doivent toujours
être conservés ils ont vécu un mandat de
5 ans dans une situation où il décidait
de tout seul et ils n'ont pas intégré
l'élection présidentielle qui a
fragilisé nos institutions à tous avec
une extrême droite qui continue
d'augmenter à monter et ils n'ont pas
intégré qu'ils étaient en majorité
relative et quand on est en majorité
relative on a une responsabilité plus
grande celle de créer les conditions du
compromis avec des gens qui ne pensent
pas comme nous et pour l'instant force
est de constater quand il s'agit de
textes de distribution nouvelle
évidemment ils arrivent à créer les
conditions de majorité quand il s'agit
de textes plus difficiles ou le dialogue
est absolument nécessaire on l'a vu sur
les retraites ils en ont été jusqu'à
présent incapable je pense que de
manière générale c'est la méthode de
gouvernement qui vont être revue je ne
le crois pas je pense que vous avez
affaire à des gens qui ont été
majoritaires je le vois au Parlement
j'ai des députés qui travaillent mais
qui ne savent pas ce que c'est le
compromis moi je viens du groupe liotte
et qui sont des gens issus des
territoires insulaires ultramarins Corse
de droite comme de gauche et qui ont un
fil conducteur celui d'avoir été en
responsabilité à l'échelle locale bien
sûr il y a des moments d'élection et
après il y a la responsabilité de faire
avancer les choses dans le cadre de
l'intérêt général et aller chercher le
voisin ou celui d'en face faire un pas
vers lui dire je pense ça et toi tu
penses autrement et finalement est-ce
qu'on est capable de se retrouver et
d'avoir des convergences ça exige de
sortir des postures et de ne pas
considérer des facto que j'ai raison que
tu as tort et que ça sera comme ça
message reçu on va parler de la LPM
puisque le député examine pendant deux
semaines la loi de programmation
militaire elle prévoit 413 milliards
d'euros sur 7 ans pour les armées les
grandes lignes de cette LPM en nom de
code avec Marco pommier
c'est un record 413 milliards d'euros de
dépenses entre 2024 et 2030 c'est 40% de
plus que pour la précédente loi de
programmation militaire objectif
transformer l'armée française et faire
face aux nouvelles menaces on vit dans
un monde plus dangereux retour de la
guerre en Europe haute menace qui reste
à un niveau extrêmement élevé deuxième
raison on est dans un monde avec des
mutations technologiques extrêmement
importantes sur le quantique sur le
cyber sur l'espace sur les fonds
sous-marins et la France a besoin de
rester au meilleur niveau près d'un
quart du budget sera consacré aux
effectifs et à l'amélioration des
rémunérations le gouvernement table sur
275 000 militaires et civils à l'horizon
2030 autre objectif consolider le stock
de munitions et commander 130 blindés
supplémentaires 5 milliards d'euros
seront consacrés au drone 6 milliards
pour le développement de l'industrie
spatiale sans oublier un porte-avion
nouvelle génération à propulsion les
républicains et le rassemblement
national pointe du doigt la répartition
de l'effort budgétaire en fait plus que
de savoir combien c'est de savoir
comment et ce qui est inquiétant dans
cette loi de programmation militaire et
de voir que les plus gros
investissements arrivent après 2027
comme si le gouvernement avait voulu
finalement attirer la lumière à lui sur
cette loi de programmation militaire en
laissant à ses successeurs la charge de
trouver les financements dans les
ressources dans les recettes publiques
parmi les priorités de cette loi de
programmation militaire l'entretien et
la modernisation de la dissuasion
nucléaire la France insoumise en
questionne la pertinence rien
aujourd'hui ne nous garantit que cette
dissuasion ne sera efficace dans les 20
30 prochaines années nous nous
souhaitons réaffirmer les engagement de
la France dans le traité de nos
proliférations qui dans son article 6
dit que
l'objectif et la dénucléarisation du
monde avec un désarmement multilatéral
en attendant la dissuasion de demeurer
le texte sera soumis au vote des députés
le 7 juin prochain avant de partir au
Sénat objectif permettre Emmanuel Macron
de promulguer la loi pour le 14 juillet
Benjamin saint tué ce que vous êtes prêt
à voter cette loi à 413 milliards
d'euros ce que vous voulez féliciter du
de l'augmentation du budget des armées
nous considérons que le monde a changé
que l'Europe qui se considérait pour
toujours en paix vérifie malheureusement
depuis l'agression perpétrée par
Vladimir Poutine et les forces russes en
Ukraine que nous sommes dans une
situation extrêmement instable et que du
coup la France doit elle-même créer les
conditions pour être en situation de
faire face à cette nouvelle situation
mais je veux le dire avec clarté nous
avons un certain nombre d'amendements à
apporter je pense à la question des
Outre-mer mais pas seulement mais nous
le regardons d'un bon œil ce que nous
disons c'est que ce gouvernement a pris
une habitude celle de projeter à long
terme les politiques publiques sans
doute que cela peut avoir un intérêt
mais cela aussi peut différer une forme
de responsabilité publique moi qui et du
local si vous dites aux gens on met en
place une trajectoire jusque 2040 et on
commencera effectivement à avoir les
effets en 2030
un certain nombre de temps déjà certains
de deux semaines sur le rail ça a été
vrai sur aujourd'hui la loi de
programmation c'est vrai sur la question
des énergies ce sera vraie on a voté le
nucléaire je l'ai voté parce que je
crois que c'est nécessaire mais on ne
sait toujours pas comment le finance
donc il y a une tentation parfois de
choisir la communication politique et de
remettre à plus tard la manière dont on
financera ses choix donc si vous me
posez la question de est-ce que nous
sommes d'accord sur l'orientation
politique la réponse est plutôt oui
moyennant un certain nombre
d'amendements sur la méthode là encore
je considère que la visée de long terme
si elle peut être nécessaire doit
trouver des réponses concrètes plus
rapidement rapidement sur ce sujet pour
augmenter notre base de réserviste le
gouvernement réfléchi à et bien remettre
en place le service militaire alors sur
la base du volontariat ce sera un
service militaire qui durait de trois à
six mois est-ce que c'est une bonne idée
je pense que c'est de la communication
tout le monde sait que ça coûte beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent et que si on doit
faire de la politique on doit faire
quelque chose de simple quand j'ai un
billet de 100 euros je fais de la
politique je dois dire où je mets c'est
100 euros je suis pas sûr que c'est sur
ces sujets là qu'il faut les mettre
aujourd'hui
à l'agenda de la semaine prochaine au
Parlement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mardi 30 mai la séance reprend avec
toujours cette loi de programmation
militaire qui est donc au menu pour la
deuxième semaine jusqu'au vote la
semaine d'après et puis le 31 mai
Benjamin c'est une et bien place à
l'examen de votre proposition de loi
proposition de loi du groupe Yot pour
abroger notamment le recul de l'âge
effectif de départ à la retraite et puis
mardi au Sénat la commission d'enquête
sur le fond Marianne poursuivra ses
auditions le lendemain le ministre de
l'Économie Bruno Le Maire présentera au
sénateur le projet loi industrie verte
et après la démission du maire de
Saint-Brevin victime des violences de
l'extrême droite et bien elle est
sénateurs entendront le préfet de la
région Pays de la Loire ainsi que le
sous-préfet de Saint-Nazaire justement
pour finir Benjamin sainte-tweet sur ce
sujet des violences face à nos élus à
nos soignants à nos policiers qu'est-ce
que vous proposez pour mieux protéger
ses agents publics la réalité c'est que
nous sommes dans une société qui est de
plus en plus violente aujourd'hui
particulièrement à l'endroit de ceux qui
représentent l'institution c'est vrai
pour nos forces de l'ordre c'est vrai
pour nos forces de sécurité de manière
générale c'est vrai pour nos
fonctionnaires c'est vrai pour nous élus
et nous devons nous interroger à ce que
nous pouvons faire collectivement pour
mieux les protéger en termes de
prévention et pour que les réponses
apportées à ces situations inacceptables
soit beaucoup plus importante et de
manière générale il faut aussi être
conscient que l'Assemblée nationale
c'est une caisse de résonance et qu'il y
a un devoir d'exemplarité de celles et
de ceux qui prennent la parole parce que
la violence même si elle est verbale
même si elle est symbolique elle peut
être répercutée dehors comme étant une
forme de légitimation ce que nous
réfutons absolument qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de l'évocation de la
décibilisation de la société comme l'a
dit Emmanuel Macron sujet de ce contexte
j'imagine qu'il y a des conseillers très
sérieux qui lui ont proposé ce terme je
ne suis pas sûr de bien comprendre moi
je pense que quoi qu'il en soit il faut
investir sur l'éducation il faut choisir
d'être au plus près de notre jeunesse et
il faut restaurer aussi une forme de
responsabilité dans la parole publique
de modération parce que nous sommes
regardés pas toujours entendu mais
observer
sans tuile et merci à tous d'avoir suivi
cette émission cette semaine on se
retrouve très bientôt ciao ciao
[Musique]